[Music]
so when you asked someone for advice on
how to lose weight chances are they'll
fall into one of two categories either
they'll tell you that losing weight is
all a matter of calories count the
calories coming in count the calories
going out and make sure you mean in a
deficit they say you can't argue with
maths then you get the people that will
say it's more to do with your hormones
it's all about being in good shape
that's about you know keto or insulin
sensitivity or it's about intermittent
fasting and that this can help them to
get better results than simply counting
your calories which can be a bit
soul-crushing as usual I think the
correct answer lies somewhere in the
middle of these two things I do find it
a little bit unhelpful when people tell
you that all you need to know to lose
weight is to count your calories because
some people can be so stubborn with that
that when someone says to them look I
have been counting my calories I'm
trying really hard I'm dieting Lots and
I'm not losing weight they have a
tendency to just say well you're lying
you're not counting your calories enough
or you're cheating or you haven't
thought of something when actually I've
witnessed firsthand people who have
counted their calories and they're still
not losing the weight likewise people
are eating tons and tons of protein tons
of calories and they're still not
building the muscle there is a little
bit more to it than that but then it's
pretty hard to argue with math if you're
burning more calories than you're eating
that means your body needs to find that
fuel from somewhere so it's going to
burn your fat store so how can it
possibly be that this doesn't work for
some people sometimes it's a normal if
you want to lose weight by counting
calories need to start by working out
your Amr that's your active metabolic
rate and this is your BMR basal
metabolic rate plus activity so the
basal metabolic rate is how many
calories you burn in order to go about
your business in order to walk in order
to blink in order to breathe in order to
just just be alive before you exercise
this is number of calories your body
needs just to maintain your systems and
order for your food to digest not a for
you to sleep and order for you to think
so that all takes energy
so once you've calculated that and then
you add on top of that how much exercise
you do in a day then you've got a good
number a rough estimate of how many
calories you're burning each day but it
really is just that it's an estimate and
for some people it's going to be way off
as we're about to see the best way to
illustrate this is to go through it and
see what's wrong with it
so let's calculate our BMR and RMR so
men you're going to start with the
number 66 but
who knows and then you're gonna plus
your weight in pounds times six point
two three then you're going to plus your
height in inches times twelve point
seven and then you're going to subtract
from that your age in years by six times
eight women you're gonna start with six
five five and you're gonna add your
weight in pounds times four point three
five then you're gonna add your height
in inches times four point seven and
from that you're gonna subtract your age
in years by four point seven because
that's our basal metabolic rate that's
how many calories we burn just to stay
upright and then on top of that you're
gonna add your activity and that's just
gonna be in multiplication using an
arbitrary number based off of roughly
how active you are on a typical day so
one point two is for people who are very
inactive people who just hang around the
house people who work them home people
who work sitting down and drive to work
and then one point nine is gonna be for
people who are highly active people who
maybe are physical laborers people who
you know move boxes for a living people
who are up on their feet all day at work
maybe they teach cycling or something so
take your number
time's up by that that's your active
metabolic rate that's roughly how many
calories you burn in a given day on a
typical day then on top of that you just
gonna add any activity you do that's
extra like exercise you'll probably
track the number of calories you burn
using a fitness tracker add that onto
that and that's how many calories you
burned that day so what's the problem
with this it all sounds very scientific
how could it possibly go wrong well
first of all that AMR is based off your
body height and your weight and your
gender but it has no indication of your
muscle mass and as we all know muscle is
far more metabolically active than fat
so if you're very muscular then you're
gonna burn calories more quickly than if
you're very overweight and you can get
around this by calculating your lean
body mass which is the amount of weight
you have without fat and then doing an
AMR calculation based off of that and
I'll leave a link in the description
down below to a article on my website
the Pioneer where you'll be able to find
those calculations with tons more to
find out more about a more accurate
figure of how many calories you might be
burning in a given day
problem is that a lot of fitness
trackers and a lot of apps a lot of diet
apps they don't ask for your body fat
percentage they don't have your lean
body mass so that AMR
or BMR is calculated based off of just
your height and your weight so it could
be completely off because if you're
someone who's you know a hundred pounds
and you're just fat or you 100 pounds in
you're just pure muscle you're gonna
burn very different numbers of calories
so another problem is it's really hard
to measure your activity level so you
might be highly active during the week
but very sedentary during the weekend or
vice-versa we might just have a week
where you're not very active because
you've twisted your ankle that can skew
your results and your AMR and your BMR
isn't going to change to reflect that
and likewise you might simply have miss
rated yourself because well a lot of
people think that the activity levels
include the exercise they're doing on
top but it doesn't because if you're
measuring your activity levels with your
fitness tracker
then you shouldn't also be counting
those calories again by saying you're an
active person so you should really only
be looking at the number of calories you
burn by walking during the day and by
being active generally going to the gym
for half an hour even if it's an intense
session isn't gonna fix it so you need
to be more active throughout the day and
so this is something to think about when
you're measuring your activity levels
and actually Fitness trackers have
something of a problem with this because
a lot of the time when they measure your
calorie burn during an exercise they
forget to measure your BMR on top of
that in other words they forget to
measure how many calories you would have
burned
anyways during the hour and then
subtract that from the number so again
you'd think that they'd be smarter than
that but a lot of them aren't and so
your numbers again might be skewed you
might think that you're being really
strict and maintaining that deficit but
actually that deficit could be a lot
smaller because the numbers aren't quite
adding up right and another thing to
think about is all the other sources of
calories that you might not have
considered when you were logging your
calorie intake so that includes things
like soda drinks Coca Cola
and lemonade these add tons of calories
to our diets and a lot of people don't
count them they just count their meals
likewise sugary coffees and things or
full fat milk these things milk on your
cereal these things add a ton of
calories and if you're only logging the
the food items you're eating and you're
forgetting about those things the oil
that you add to your cooking the
seasoning you're forgetting those things
then your numbers again gonna be skewed
but even with that all taken into
account there's still big problems
inherent in the whole concept of an AMR
and a BMR because ultimately these
numbers allow no individual differences
they are a completely set number set in
stone
they don't take into account how
metabolisms differ and this is where
some people will say you're just making
excuses you're just saying you know I
can't lose weight because of my
metabolism when actually you're just
lazy and know these people if that's
your view then you just you either lack
sympathy and empathy or you just haven't
encountered someone who's genuinely
struggles to lose weight or who
genuinely struggles to build muscle
because there are huge differences with
our metabolism which just aren't shown
in an EMR or BMR consider this for
instance if you were to take steroids
right now you're am I on your BMR would
remain the exact same however you'd burn
a lot more fat and build a lot more
muscle thanks to all that extra
testosterone so that's proof that the am
I on the BMR doesn't take everything
into account or consider women who start
all contraceptive pills and they start
to gain or lose weight rapidly because
they've altered their hormone balance or
think about someone with hypothyroidism
that means that they don't produce the
same thyroid hormones they gain weight
they find it much harder to lose weight
they have much lower energy like why
something someone with hypothyroidism is
gonna lose a lot of weight and be
bouncing off the walls then you have
things like insulin sensitivity which
can vary from person to person diabetes
a song with diabetes again there am on
that BMI is gonna be the same as song
without diabetes even though the way
that they lose and gain weight is going
to be drastically different and I'm not
saying that you might have
hypothyroidism or hyperthyroidism I'm
not saying that you are taking steroids
but the point is you shouldn't think of
these things as binary so you're not
someone who has hypothyroidism or
doesn't have it you have thyroid
hormones and for each of us we have
different quantities and different
strengths of these hormones likewise
different people have different amounts
of testosterone and different people
have different amounts of estrogen or
their body responds to it differently so
think of it more like a spectrum you're
somewhere on that spectrum you might be
very close to being clinically diagnosed
with hypothyroidism with diabetes you
might be very close to pre-diabetes but
not realize it you could be perfectly
healthy but you're just so on who
because of that hormone difference finds
it harder or easier to build muscle or
to lose weight etc and
this isn't gonna be shown in your ami or
BMR so it's not that it's not scientific
it's not that you know counting the
numbers doesn't work the problem is with
counting the numbers because if you're
someone who has more testosterone or who
has more of the right thyroid hormones
you're going to burn more calories but
your AMR won't tell you that and
vice-versa
another example is your microbiome the
gut flora that lives inside your gut so
bacteria we often think of as being bad
for us as being germs as being viruses
but actually a lot of bacteria is good
for us we have tons of bacteria living
in our stomachs living in our bowels
that perform a whole host of jobs inside
our bodies they break down our food they
release neurotransmitters they help to
fortify our immune system and when this
gut flora gets imbalance when you have
the wrong amounts or kinds of bacteria
you don't have enough then you lose some
of those functions and that's another
reason might lose or gain weight I
watched a video recently by what I've
learned I've mentioned that channel a
couple of times really enjoying it at
the moment
talking about the microbiome and talking
about how one woman who had a fecal
transplant which is disgusting it means
that you're transplanting someone else's
poo into you in order to inherit their
microbiome they did this in order to
support her immune system I believe but
as a result she gained weight she
doesn't change anything else about her
diet which she'd gained a ton of weight
because she basically inherited the
microbiome of someone who was overweight
and this made it hard for her to remain
in shape herself so that's another
factor that you might not have
considered something as simple as
supporting your gut flora when they take
antibiotics it kills off these bacteria
and you might find yourself a meal that
could lead to weight gain so when we
actually look at the biome of people who
are overweight or people who have
diabetes they tend to have a lot more of
this from mcclarty's family you can
support your microbiome can support your
gut flora by using yogurts by using
probiotic foods by using things like
kefir so that's something to look into
and it's certainly something I'm gonna
look into more on this channel because
your gut flora also has a big impact on
your psychology and your mental
performance so that's right up my alley
and of course I haven't even addressed
the alleged differences in the ways that
our body responds to different types of
food there's
the thermic effect the notion that
certain foods require calories just to
digest more so than others there's the
notion that protein is less readily
stored as fat there's the idea that
complex carbs and fats release their
energy more slowly and thereby a less
like to spike our blood sugar and to
trigger an insulin response causing us
to store fat when we're not currently
active and don't currently need the
energy
so all these things might also play a
role and that explain why some people
have success with things like the slow
carb diet or again going to be more fat
based diet rather than a carb based diet
but again we're all different and what
works for you might be different from
someone else so if you've tried one diet
and it doesn't work rather than being
dogmatic and thinking that's the only
way try one of the others even if it
doesn't work for the reason that you
think it should work you might find that
your body responds well to it all this
anecdotal evidence doesn't come from
nowhere
and believe it or not as crazy as it
might sound your personality even and
your mood can also have a big impact on
the number of calories you burn because
if you're somebody who is very anxious
very overstressed at the moment very
overworked you're gonna produce a lot of
cortisol cortisol as we know signals
hunger it makes you more hungry it also
encourages your body to store fat and in
particular visceral factors they're
really unhealthy kind then on the other
hand if you're someone is very relaxed
very easygoing you might produce a less
myostatin because cortisol and myostatin
correlate with each other
myostatin is a molecule that signals the
breakdown of muscles so somebody who's
more relaxed and easygoing might in fact
or certainly less stressed at work might
in fact find it easier to build more
muscle to remain more anabolic and once
again I'm not saying that this is a
bigger factor than the calories you eat
I'm not saying am I on BMR as users I'm
just saying that all these things should
be taken into account when you're
looking at losing or gaining weight I
often recommend that people are trying
to gain muscle live like lions I say
they shouldn't just sleep more train
more and eat more they should relax more
they should be more laid-back they
should try and reduce their stress and
you're gonna stay more anabolic you're
gonna build more muscle
for breakfast this morning the second
for breakfast to deserve a nice
breakfast and of course your sleep has a
massive impact on how many calories you
can burn it's been proven time and time
again the sleeping better helps to burn
more calories and not getting enough
sleep leads to weight gain and low
energy of course which is going to
impact on the quality of your workouts
and again this isn't factored into an
AMR or BMR it's not factored into
counting your calories so what should
you do how should you lose weight or
gain weight if you're struggling - like
I say start by calculating your calories
start by tracking them start with a by
calculating macros but then if it's not
working for you right away
and on top of it anyways look at other
factors look at all the factors that
contribute to your weight loss or your
weight gain look at things like your
sleep
look at how active you are during the
day look at if you're overstressed look
at perhaps supplements or mineral
deficits and then they're in nutrient
deficiencies so if you're not getting
enough of a certain nutrient you're
going to find it harder to burn fat or
to build muscle because either that
nutrient is involved in mobilizing fat
cells or it's involved in the creation
of an important hormone or
neurotransmitter so again that's
something where you can try and try to
cut calories in to lose weight that way
but actually maybe you just needed more
magnesium could be that simple and
seeing as we've discussed that muscle is
more metabolically active than fat and
helps to burn more fat even at rest
it follows that another way you can help
yourself to burn more calories is to
build more muscle this is a big mistake
that a lot of people make they think the
best way to get slim is just to do loads
and loads of cardio when in fact doing
some form of resistance training can
actually be even more effective because
when you're doing this not only you burn
your calories by using the muscles and
exerting yourself but you then encourage
further fat burning throughout the day
because you've got more muscle mass for
your body to maintain and one of the
best things you can do is to train your
legs if you're skipping legs day then
you're skipping some of the biggest
muscles in your body
and you could be burning many more
calories by just bulking up the legs and
I'm not saying that it will be that
simple for you I'm not saying that any
of these things are necessarily more
important than an AMI
PMR all I'm saying is that there's so
many different factors you shouldn't
just look at it as a black and white
thing and as well as considering your
calories to begin with I'd also highly
recommend considering your lifestyle in
general could you be sleeping better are
you getting all of your important
nutrients are you getting all of your
amino acids other supplements that you
haven't tried are you active during the
day getting enough sunlight are you
highly stressed at work all these things
could have a big impact on you should
you check with your doctor to find out
whether you might be insulin resistant
or whether you might have polycystic
ovaries
could it be medication you're on all
these things consider all these things
because they do play a role a lot of the
time so if you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like please share it around
please comment down below and let me
know what you think do you complete
disagree of me do you think it's just a
matter of counting calories or do you
think there lots of other factors
involved as well
are there any other big factors that
I've missed that you think I should have
addressed if you'd like to continue this
discussion further then I recommend
checking out the link in the description
down below get to the buying it I've
just added a forum where we can talk
about this and many other topics whether
it's nootropic whether it's bodybuilding
whether it's Fitness with its parkour
martial arts or just Dragon Ball Z
because I've been loving the discussions
we've had down below I love the fact
that you guys talk to each other as well
and I thought why not create a place
where you can properly discuss you can
create a account and you can sign up and
we'll talk about all those things you
have any questions about fitness or
brain training or Loutre picks or any
suggestions for topics you'd like me to
post of course I'll still answer you
down below there as well but that's
another forum another place for us to
discuss those things so yeah check it
out if you're interested thanks a ton
for watching stay tuned for stuff like
bodybuilding Fitness nootropics
technology working online
self-development brain training martial
arts parkour Fitness that all sounds
good then thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now